كما اعلنت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
لوجان ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت قريه
نوفيكا
وتامر اهلا بكما في هذا اليوم وابدا معك
سلام اذا قلب قلب يتعرض للقصف والهجمات
مستمره حدثينا عامه
واخر يعني ما تسمعين ايضا من تطورات
سياسيه عندك تفضل
ليلى كانت ليلى قاسيه يوم امس على مدينه
دانيتسكي وسط المدينه تعرض لقصف مركز قصف
صاروخيا ومدفعي احدى اكبر مستشفيات
المدينه مستشفى كالينين تعرضت
لسقوط صاروخين على الاقل ما ادى الى اصابه
احد المباني قتل احد المرضى داخل المستشفى
ولكن الاطقم الطبيه بحسب السلطات تمكنت من
اجلاق باقي المرضى من المبنى الذي اصيب في
الاثناء هناك قصف متجدد من المواقع
الروسيه نستطيع ان نسمع المدفعيه الروسيه
تعمل منذ صباح هذا اليوم تستهدف المواقع
الاوكرانيه القريبه من مدينه دمياط بشكل
المكثف لا ادري ان كنتم تسمعون
اصداء
ليله ايضا السلطات المحليه قالت
السلطات المحليه في دانياتس قالت ان
المدفعيه الروسيه تمكنت من تدمير موقعين
على الاقل من تلك المواقع التي استهدفت
بالقصف مدينه وسط مدينه دنيتس ليلى امس
اييه الرئيس الموالي لروسيا هنا في
دانياتس تحدث ايضا عن تحقيق تقدم في منطقه
مريانكا قال ان القوات الروسيه باتت في
منتصف المدينه وان القتال لا يزال مستمر
لدفع القوات الاوكرانيه خارج مدينه
ماريانكا ماريانكا فقط للتفكير هي مدينه
محاديه لجنوب مدينه دانيتس وتلتصق تقريبا
باحد احياء هذه المدينه ايضايات الصباح
اليوم السلطات المحليه في مدينه خرسايسك
التي تبعد قرابه 15 كلم عن مدينه تقول
السلطات فيسك ان المدينه تعرضت على الاقل
سقوط اربع صواريخ هاي مارس وان السلطات
المحليه تحاول حصر الاضرار في هذه الاثناء
ليلى
شكرا سلام
الى خير سنه وزبروجا والجبهه الجنوبيه وما
يجري فيها ومجمل هذه الثورات مع تامر
صمادي مراسل الجزيره تصريحات الرئيس بخصوص
الحدود الشماليه مع بيلروسيا وايضا بخصوص
وتصريحات عسكريه اوكرانيه عما يجري على
الجبهات الجنوبيه والقصف الروسي وطائرات
شاهد الايرانيه التفاصيل معك تامر
في خطاب به الليلي بانه يجب ان تتهيا
اوكرانيا لسينا لعديد السيناريوهات كما
قال فيما يتعلق بالحدود مع روسيا وبلاسيا
وتحدث عن ضروره اليقظه وتحدث عن انه هنالك
مخطط يستهدف همم العاصمه الاكرانيه واشار
ايضا الى تطورات في محمود وفي خير سون وفي
زمن الرجوله وتحدث عن اشتعال الجبهات وقال
فيه محمود ما زالت القوات الاوكرانيه
تسيطر على المدينه رغم محاولات الجانب
الروسي لتدمير المدينه وجدران المدينه كما
اشار واا تحدث ايضا عن التطورات في خير
صور وعموم المقاطعات الجنوبيه وقال بان
القوات الاوكرانيه تكبد الجانب الروسي
خسائر بشكل تدريجي وقال نعمل على يعني قطع
الامدادات اللوجستيه عن القوات الروسيه
المتواجده هناك لكن في الحقيقه تطور
الابرص كان صباح هذا اليوم عندما هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه وهمم
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه بان العاصمه كيف
تعرضت للاستهداف من قبل مسيرات ايرانيه
الصنع من نوع شاهد وقال بان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت 15 طائره من دون طيار في
كياف قال بان العاصمه تضررت لاضرار تحديدا
فيما يخص البنيه التحتيه التي وصفها
بالمهمه وفي المجمل تحدث القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه عن اكثر من 35 طائره من نوع
شاهد استهدفت العاصمه وعدد من المقاطعات
الجنوبيه تحديدا ميكو لايف خيرسون واشار
الى ان ال- او اشارت القوات الجويه الى ان
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت بالفعل
نحو 30 طائره من تلك الطائرات الدفاعات
الجويه طيله فجر اليوم وهي تعمل في
ميكولايت في خيرسون فيزا في دين برو ايضا
وفقا لقلسلطات الاوكرانيه
تطور الابراج واللافت هنا في خرسانه تواجد
في احدى القرى همم القريبه من خطى كما
ساده هو المشهد هذا هذه هي الصوره دمار
اينما نظرت زين اينما تحركت ستجد بيوت
مدمره مكسوفه
والناسوا من تلك البيوت او من هذه البيوت
وذلك في العديد من القرى في قلب المدينه
التي تعرضت ايضا خلال الساعه الاخيره الى
قصف مكثف من قبل القوات الروسيه تحدثت همم
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه في المدينه
عن تجدد القصف على مبنى الاداره المحليه
في المدينه وفي الحقيقه نحن يوم امس كنا
في قلب المدينه وراء سدنا يعني نزوح كبير
همم من قبل المؤسسات الحكوميه الدوائر
الحكوميه مراكز الشرطه وانا اتحدث اليك
ايضا يتجدد القسم مره اخرى يمكنني
الاستماع اليه بشكل واضح في محيط هذه
القريه كما قلت الواقعه على
التماس وتقول السلطات الاوكرانيه بان
الساعات الاخيره منذ فجر اليوم حتى هذه
الساعه قصفت مقاطعه خيرسون عموم مقاطعه
خيرسون اكثر من 70 مره من قبل القوات
الروسيه وذلك بالمدفعيه الثقيله على الطرف
الاخر تتجدد اعمال القصف المتبادل المدفعي
بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه تحديدا
على ضفتين هاردينيبر من خيرسون ومن
زباروجيا يوم امس تحدث السلطات الاوكرانيه
عن ان القوات الروسيه تعمل على تعزيز
الاجراءات التحصينات في خط الدفاع الاول
الثاني الثالث على الضفه التي تسيطر عليها
في جنيبر وتقول القوات الاوكرانيه انها
تكثف من القصف لمزيد من الانسحاب للقوات
الروسيه بالتجاه خطوط متاخرا نعم